des armoires prête à accueillir des
serveurs informatiques c'est un
datacenter la nouvelle infrastructure du
groupe atos dans son activité de cyber
sécurité
quelques semaines après avoir posé la
première pierre de son futur centre de
recherche et développement
alors vous êtes dans le module 2 seule
différence ce sont les couleurs
le but de tout ça c'est se repérer dans
l'espace parle par le biais par le biais
des couleurs caractéristiques de ce data
center sa modularité aujourd'hui de
modules sont opérationnels soit 1300 m²
à terme 8 modules composeront
l'établissement sur un espace de 8000 m²
objectif renouveler les datacenter
existence sur les normes
environnementales et les capacités
informatiques les clés ce site c'est
vraiment un site qui est au coeur de
notre stratégie d'investissement pour
nos clients
externe à travers les data center mais
également pour nous mêmes pour pouvoir
avec nos ingénieurs de haute renommée
développer des ordinateurs de très
hautes performances quantique des
algorithmes quantique pour demain et
également tous des produits de
cybersécurité le département des
yvelines a accompagné atos hauteur de
5,5 millions d'euros à travers une aide
à l'innovation et l'acquisition foncière
d'un terrain pour le mettre à
disposition aider les entreprises à
créer de la richesse c'est la seule
façon de faire peut puissent ensuite
avoir des politiques sociales
redistributive
les premiers clients d'atos installons
leurs serveurs en janvier 2019 des
partenaires du secteur de la santé de la
défense ou encore de la distribution